mothers against drug deaths wants to
close the open air drug markets in san
francisco
and in california and eventually
to the rest of the nation we don't
believe that it's healthy for
communities
for the children or the people living in
the communities and it's not healthy for
the drug addicts or the mentally ill
people that have access to those drugs
without any type of repercussion
[Music]
my son
who is addicted to fentanyl and living
on the streets of san francisco
has told me that it's like
san francisco's like hell
because you can get everything that you
want to stay addicted very very easily
and there's no pressure to get well so
he's in bondage
to this and it's we've tried to get him
well
but because san francisco makes it so
hard to get off of these drugs and
they're always right there in your face
even in the linkage center even in the
places where you go to get help it's
it's really really difficult mayor breed
opened a linkage center in san francisco
in the tenderloin and we were really
excited about that because it was
supposed to link
people that are on the streets
to
resources
that could possibly help them get well
into rehabilitation or get some form of
housing my son told me when he first
went to the linkage center
he
couldn't believe that people were using
and selling inside the linkage center
um
it was a place that he that they're
supposed to go the ads are supposed to
go to
get help and i've only seen the open
drug market growing it's not
getting smaller and i'm seeing younger
and younger people coming into the city
my son
mentioned that also he's concerned
because he's seeing kids that look like
high school students coming into the
city buying fentanyl and then going back
out on bart and taking that into the
suburbs
he's also seeing them use in the city
so i'm getting very very concerned
about this spreading further outside of
san francisco and into the suburbs we've
been
talking to um mayors of other cities to
let them know that they need to put out
a warning to their citizens that san
francisco is not a place to allow their
teenagers
to go and enjoy themselves it's just too
dangerous